happy friday everybody welcome to
another edition of
logo therapy logo redo and today's show
we're going to be jumping right into
skillshare we're going to be talking
about logos that you love
or actually logos that you love to hate
so this is the redesign
and today we have joining us alissa
metznick
and she's originally from estonia but
she's currently residing in ireland if
you want to check out some of her work
go to alyssa.works
alyssa.works i wanted to say dot com
after that but it's just a list
that works and this is some of our work
it's actually pretty diverse
considering most of our logo therapists
have a portfolio
mostly just of logos so i see typography
i see a lot of graphic design
and a bit of lettering but the logo
we're taking on today and i didn't even
realize this mark
skillshare has a new logo i'm not used
to seeing this one so i'm curious
as to where we go with this but before i
do that i have to ask alyssa
why why are you taking on the skillshare
logo
so hi guys and thank you so much for
having me on the show chris
happy to have you i said it to you
before we went live but that felt like
uh
something i wanted to say again because
it's really fun to be here
so we uh so i chose skillshare because
i was really annoyed when i saw the
rebrand
and mainly because for almost a year
until that rebrand actually happened
i kept waiting for them to launch a
rebrand because it felt like
it is such um for them it felt like it's
a time it time to start it's
time to start evolving and they weren't
doing that
so skillshare is one of my favorite
places
and i was really waiting for them to
launch something really amazing and
spectacular but they didn't
um their brand is pretty up to date
obviously they've rebranded literally in
2020
but it doesn't it lacks
something for me it feels like they
literally
went and googled um
logo or identity trends of 2020 2019
and did exactly that they went
very expected root and actually i feel
like their old identity was really loved
by design community
even though it was kind of like old and
outdated it had a concept to it people
were used to seeing colors
um and people were in general really
used to seeing it and they just
crossed it over completely and launched
something completely new that doesn't
doesn't seem to have too much meaning or
concept behind it so i'm just gonna run
for this really quickly so what they
went for
is um this kind of like mixed lowercase
mixed uppercase
um logo typeface um
and as their system bases they are using
this scribble that they say represents
creative journey
and that creative journey isn't linear
and it is
um kind of like a complicated pathway so
that is the rationale behind what
they're doing and
they launched a new strategy which i
feel like is maybe a right strategy for
them
because they used to position themselves
as like um
a platform where anyone can learn from
anyone
um but since then a lot of different
platforms that provide education online
launched
um so and a lot of their courses
are focused on creativity anyway so i
feel like they just sort of caught up
with their audience
um and decided to double down on
creative audience
um and put a positioning forward that
says explore your creativity
and that is kind of like how their brand
guidelines play out
can i ask you what do you think before i
go further yeah for sure
well first i want to thank everybody
that's tuning in live
some people have been saying they've
been waiting this for days
so thank you for your patience we should
have a virtual line mark where we can
see them queue up
so thanks for hanging in there with us
i'm also excited to see where
alyssa takes this design now the
original logo i never loved it's thin
it feels a little dated with the rounded
corners and the two hands coming
together
i don't think that's the image we want
to put out there in the world of
creatives
as hands because you know that's a
that's like a derogatory term
like you're just hands like you're just
somebody to move the mouse a mouse
jockey
so i don't like that at all so when i
saw this logo
i thought hey this is it's kind of more
my cup of tea a bold
sans-serif typeface working on a tighter
configuration so it stacks nicely so it
scales and reduces well
and the black and green i like it's
fresh i don't know what the real
the scribble really means anyways but i
like that they're
going in this bolder fresher direction
but
as people say on the chat every time you
do a rebrand you risk
alienating your longtime die hard loyal
fans
i understand that's the case but
progress has to happen
so that that's my initial thoughts
yeah and to an extent i definitely agree
with that i feel like
the identity that they launched is a
step forward for sure
but i personally would have loved to see
an identity that
plays more on the one that they had
previously and evolves
um together with their audience rather
than
takes it out completely and launches
something entirely new
um so that's what i wanted to explore
today so it was
time to evolve for them i feel like they
lost a bit of a brand recognition that
they have built up
and potentially alienated some of the
audience i don't have those facts so you
know i can't say that
i i wasn't happy and i'm their their
audience so
it's an audience of one i'm designing
for myself today
and that's totally okay and you're the
boss so you get to do what you want
i have to ask you this question the
typeface that you're using for your
presentation is really bold chunky
typeface
what typeface is that uh it's euclid
square
euclid square okay i like it
it has some interesting properties to it
it came from a really interesting
thai foundry called swiss typefaces
everyone should check them out they are
really good there we go
that's an unsponsored plug right there
guys we give it away for free
um so before going
and i'll try to go through this part
really quickly so we can get into the
process but
it it has some of the important um
information that i use to make my
decisions because
i don't actually really like designing
logos and i try to get to the system
part as soon as i can
and being very intentional with what i'm
doing
really helps me to get to that as
quickly as possible
um and the first step that i usually do
is that i look at their competition like
what market landscape do they exist in
um not necessarily to see if there's any
gaps although that's too
but um to see what what's their
positioning and what do they have to
offer
kind of like um in addition to those
different platforms and
master class for example is
the is a platform that is very much
about kind of
it's about luxury it's about um to a
certain extent
empowerment but they very much survive
on
the reputation of the people and it's
highly curated
um and a very kind of it's it's a bit
like an exclusive
members club almost right
um domestica is an interesting one
it is becoming really popular recently
uh they are also focused on creatives
but the number one difference between
them and skillshare
um and this is what gave me some of the
ideas later on
is that you can pay per course and the
courses are usually quite cheap
and skillshare is a subscription um
just to quickly browse through these
there are a lot of platforms like
coursera for example that
um are coming across
more as a professional and a skill based
training so they trying to teach you for
a profession or to
help you gain your skills they're very
much focused on achievement
that's what skillshare doesn't do we've
got creative life
um which has a good mixture between
creative courses mainly a lot of
photography because chase
jarvis who founded the creative life um
is a photographer or used to be a
photographer himself
and i feel like a lot of their audience
is probably chase jarvis
fan um because he has a really strong
personal brand
um teachable uh not gonna stop on that
very much but skillshare is a platform
that
is is actually the only one of all of
these platforms
um that is um
where anyone can become a teacher so you
can launch your own skillshare course
and they help you to bring audience to
watch your course whether
something like teachable you can launch
your course but you have to have your
own audience
um future learn is one of the
kind of platforms where you can
learn university level courses but again
it's really
focused on achieving um
some sort of certificate or degree it's
not as much of a flat
a fun platform but what i like about
them is that from their identity
you can clearly see that they are um
promoting the education of the future so
like you can have a first glance of this
and you already know what they're about
and just a few other ones which don't
i feel like don't have a lot to do with
skillshare because
skillshare comparing to them is
definitely a lot more
fun platform to be on um but lynda.com
linkedin learning has a lot of creative
courses
khan academy is more focused on
kids education and they are making
education accessible for everyone
um career upskill focused udacity
is um another one of those and there's
very
i couldn't find too much difference
between them and coursera
um but again it is
they don't do not come across as fun
platforms to be on you just sort of
go there and learn what you need to and
go out
um so what makes skillshare unique is
focus on creativity
and you can launch your own course there
alongside big names like cheap kid polo
share
ellen lupton and your course will be
right among them i think this is a
pretty unique value proposition
um anyone can be a teacher
and it is a subscription and i think
this is a really important bit because a
subscription means that you have to keep
coming back there
you don't learn how to design a logo you
don't learn how to design
identity there has to be a reason for
you to keep coming back
um and
shall i stop it here in case you have
anything to address
no i i think it's kind of interesting
all the competitors you brought up you
might have forgotten what company but
that's okay
my ego is not hurt please continue
that is completely not because i did not
think of you
but we could say uh thank you for doing
our competitor research for us
yeah thank you every day there seems to
be one more future
uh course or university that's popping
up so that's now the third
future university that's not us just let
you guys know
future is the best one guys all go to
the future especially if you're a
designer
don't go to skillshare
it's all good no skillshare is great we
have a subscription
right yeah i actually don't i think i
need to renew it
um so i've kind of slightly tweaked
their brand message because that was
helping me to design more
um it's not a proper full-on strategy so
it could be good or bad but that was
something that was helping me make it a
bit more tangible
because the way well they um what they
say about them
themselves currently which is um explore
your creativity i think
i cannot visualize it i i don't
understand how
to visualize it that seems like a really
a bland sentence to me
so instead i went for a place where
inspiration finds you
and you can find inspiration for doing
or you can find inspiration for teaching
because when you teach you actually
learn a lot as well
and another step in my process which i
usually do pretty quickly and mindlessly
is um
identifying kind of like a key theme so
that it helps me to design a logo so
that when i'm starting to do it i
already know what i need to do
um and the key themes that i wanted to
um
bring up is lifelong learning
industries crossover and collaboration
and
um inspiration so lifelong learning
again
because it's a subscription um
industries crossover and collaboration
because
i think there's something interesting
and trying to encourage
um like let's say you have a designer
that's part of a
skillshare um community they're
they're they're using your subscription
to keep that designer there i feel like
it would be really interesting to try to
encourage them to try music
and maybe that helps them find an
inspiration um because most people get
stuck in like their one
area that they're in and to make that
subscription worthwhile
if the platform was encouraging you to
try like a lot of different things that
could be
really fun and inspiration um
and then i usually pull together kind of
like a really quick mood board
that i'm not necessarily using as such
but just to get some sort of visual
representation of what we're talking
about so
a lot of infinity symbols on this one in
the streakers over and collaboration
like maybe there's you know some sort of
mixed-media approach or a split screen
something
happening um
i see another way
it's very clever i see where this is
going
i don't need to interrupt keep going i'm
just providing some comments from the
peanut gallery
and another way of this would be kind of
like intertwined shapes
or these are great references that you
put together by the way
very nice yes especially the carol
martens
um one of my favorite printmakers
designers ever
if someone's not heard of him please
check him out he's
dedicated 80 years of his life on
figuring out how to make shapes work in
an interesting way
there's another unsponsored plug right
there mark we just dropped another area
unsponsored plug right there i i do want
to make one comment real quick
um if you guys are watching this you're
probably getting the feeling that i'm
getting
alyssa's got a very sophisticated taste
the way that she curates and lays things
out
her topography is really really sharp
and just as a graphic designer myself i
i really appreciate this i just wanted
to comment there
oh thank you chris it means a lot coming
from you
um and inspiration again could we bring
split screen
into talking about inspiration when
something comes from ordinary to
something extraordinary
um or could be represent flow
as inspiration or wave many would be
familiar with the concept of inspiration
uh when you're inspired you're feeling
like you're in the flow and the reason i
do this before i start designing
anything is so that
when i'm designing let's say if i start
with the logos so that when i'm
designing that logo
i can start thinking of a system in my
head like how is it going to start
playing out in the future
um and now we're finally into the fun
part let's
all right very exciting
so as i said in the beginning
i wanted to see how we can build on
the previous identity skillshare had
without
like um deleting it completely
and starting fresh um and
some of the most interesting features of
what they had
where um kind of like the two colors
coming together
because that to me speaks about
collaboration and also to their name as
well
literally sharing skills um but also
there were some
interesting things happening in the logo
which go back to those some key themes
that um
i started outlining in the beginning so
this was their logo
yep you could read a letter s inside
that shape
and there's also something interesting
about skillshare
so there's a double lesson there so that
also already gives an ideas of what the
logo could start becoming
um and i am immediately jumping to like
double s monogram in my head
um there's two of these curves
um meeting together
which again speaks to me to um
collaboration and skills coming together
um
whatever you want to call it and
something
that speaks to life uh lifelong learning
to me as well
you could sort of with a bit of a
stretch but you could start seeing
infinity symbol inside that logo as like
a closing down shapes yes you get a
bunch of designers together you stay on
a logo and
they become rorschach tests and people
see what they want to see
i for sure see this of course there's
two hands in there and
i'll i'll go with you for now yeah i can
sort of see an infinity thing there
okay so these are all the things i
wanted to consider when i started doing
sketches
and if that's hopefully gonna play there
you go so we're now
in my sketching process and i've
literally just
i'm doing this on procreate and i've
literally just
um started tracing the logo and seeing
where it takes me
i like that you've gone in and
deconstructed the original logo
and i think you're you've done it better
than the most because
people will talk about it and then
they'll move on but i really like how
you're examining it
and taking it apart and trying to
preserve some of the heritage and
original identity
so that's that's really cool to see
so what are you working in here is this
uh illustrator
uh procreate okay so i drawn my ipad
oh all right there's
actually i usually used to start drawing
on paper
um but since
um i got an ipad to do lettering on
i actually realized that it's really
useful for logo design process because
um you're you're actually a bit it frees
you up to delete
certain bits and start looking into
negative space and it's a bit easier to
do that than on paper so your
your process can actually go a lot
faster
but paper is just as good but these are
nice and sharp
your sketching skills are really tight
i like all the different variations too
a lot of a lot of exploration that
you've done here
i can see in some of these they feel a
little retro like 70s or 80s
and then some a little bit more modern
as you're working through this okay
so what i was really trying to do as you
um and you'll probably i don't know if
you can see my mouse but you can
probably see it in some of them like i
wanted to
um so i wanted to have the feeling of
the two shapes coming together
as the original logo does i wanted to
um see if i can make it work with the
two original
um kind of like i don't know how to call
it like half circle
outline shapes um
or i wanted to see if i can um
[Music]
i think actually that's all i was doing
i was playing with some negative space
around here but that
didn't seem to be yeah i think before
you're describing
two interlocking semi-circles right
uh yes yeah yes kind of
it definitely started with them
so that was like i think it was this one
oh actually we'll see now or like two
macaronis
or two macaronis
so from here i've selected this logo
uh i was like whoa fantastic great i
found it i can
imagine how this is going to start all
coming together
yes and
then i found out that this is exactly
the same as the shazam logo
that was a really devastating day
oh no this happens all the time when
you're dealing with pure geometry and
simple shapes
it's bound to conflict with something
that you find
yes but it was even if it was something
really small perhaps it would be
possible to over
like kind of overlook it or tweak it
slightly but for something as big as
shazam there was no way i could make it
work
yeah um
so i was in a bit of a pickle
so i returned back to sketches
and started seeing what else interesting
was in there that i didn't
find before and
that um that shape started standing out
so can you pause here can you pause here
for a second
the ones that i see on screen the one
that speaks to me the most
is number three if we're looking at the
top
row three over from the left side
i really like that it's really bold and
there's something really cool about that
the proportions feel pretty good mm-hmm
that's really interesting that you say
that because um
i didn't think that when i was designing
but actually
now that you say it i might return into
it
and explore maybe there's something else
in there yeah
that's where you're saying to me right
now like uh shut up chris
i got this under control i really need
your opinion right now
but you know the other one that stands
out to me is
number seven which is on the second row
three and from the left just underneath
my first favorite um
but i think i'm just looking for the
right proportion between these things
and
one is taller and i don't know why but
the taller one feels
um maybe a little bit more elegant and
not so squat and not so squarish
so it maybe it feels faster in its
movement and more dynamic but that's
just me
speaking design nonsense but i think
those are
two very good options to look at i
thought we're all here to speak about
design nonsense
but i have to call it out when i do it
you know because people on the internet
later gonna watch like
there he goes spewing that design speak
yeah it's true
it's just interpretation and it's
subjective and i'm
i have an opinion as you do and i'm not
saying mine is right or yours is wrong
i'm just sharing my opinion okay please
continue
okay
so similarly to you i felt like
proportions are kind of wrong so i
started kind of
i started refining it a little bit and
that was fairly quick
it still feels wrong but i decided that
i'm gonna start resolving that
in um illustrator
is this
you know one of the reasons why i had
preferred the
uh the top three in versus number seven
was because
i'm not looking at the negative shape uh
when you have
something like this you really have to
take into consideration what's the
negative shape
and when i saw it last time it kind of
looked like a toy duck
you know i'm talking about like a rubber
ducky when you take a bath
it kind of did it did a little bit yeah
so we're going to see where
where alyssa takes this now what are you
oh my god i'm afraid nowhere well i
think the duck stays
it's uh you're gonna find a meaning for
the duck that's like a surprise
it represents life or something yeah
you know it's like ducked up mind it was
um
sorry go on chris no no it's gonna be a
dumb i was trying to
help you find a reason why ducks are
important
because when life throws a punch at you
you gotta duck and that's why you gotta
go oh
gosh dad jokes are awesome
i'm trying i'm trying like in the
presentation this is what i would do
guys
really i would sit there like you know
sometimes you gotta zag man you gotta
talk that's very true very true
you gotta tell a story that's repeatable
and so if you tell the right story
the clients fall in love with it you
tell the wrong story they
go oh dad joke
so i notice here these are not perfect
circles these are more elliptical right
perfect circle no it's definitely not i
was just trying to
match the curves
i feel like when you start designing
with like
i don't know i'm maybe i i'm it's just
me who's like not really good at this
but i cannot
design with like perfect shapes or
anything i'm not
this is probably a first time i've ever
built a grid for a logo
oh interesting then
um but back to the duck conversation i
thought it was an
s inside okay
to me uh when i was designing it it
looked like an s
inside what i wanted to do is like oh
yeah so that's where i stopped okay
and that's how i've created it
and i went back to their original colors
and tweaked them slightly so
they look a bit more uplifted and nicer
combined
and now we can look at the way i did the
word mark
and how i was looking at type bearings
and one thing i just wanted to comment
on is like i like how you showed us that
you hit that roadblock where you
saw that the logo looked like shazam
you're like oh okay well we got to
switch gears here
now that you found that out you go ahead
and uh
you know went through more explorations
until you found what you liked
yeah it was um i i was
pretty much in love with this logo so it
was really hard to realize that shazam
owns it
that happens all the time
now what typeface are using the same one
yes uh
it is called euclid square so i use the
same for representation as i used it
here
um and
i started what this video doesn't show
is that before in a process i usually
um lay out like a couple of typefaces
before i even start designing the logo
and see which one i like just so i'm not
completely stuck when i'm designing and
once i like something i can sort of run
with it and then change it if i need to
um and
what i'm trying to remember what am i
doing here
oh yeah so i started seeing how like
this type locks up with the logo
one thing i did to it and i'll repeat
that step a bit later on
is um i tweaked the curve
not the curve i tweaked the slant
of an r and um
the width of uh letters
l so that it kind of like stacks up a
bit nicer
but i think i'll do it again soon
there's a comment in here it says you're
a really good designer
and i 100 agree
thank you i appreciate it i've not been
doing it for too long so
shh don't tell anybody yeah just a
secret
um so oh actually that was an
interesting part i'm gonna go back
quickly
yeah so you put an s to fill it in
but at a different shade or different
color
what i was trying to do um
i want i wonder if i can stop it
somewhat no that was not stuff
oh my god i'm joining everything so
i'm gonna go i need to go back
i'm thinking how can i show it but i
can't so i'm just gonna
basically when i was looking at this um
when i was looking uh when i um made a
word mark with
euclid square i realized that it really
annoys me that the angle
of the s is different the angle of the
logo
of an s in the logo is different to the
word mark
because it has a lot more um kind of
like a closed in s
and then the i like uh it's a perfect 40
degree angle inside the logo
uh so that felt kind of like but it
doesn't create too much harmony to me
and what i started doing um you'll see
that in a bit
uh is i took a futurist because that's
how it's built
and i started seeing if there's any way
i can create
a word mark with futura but that didn't
felt like it works to me
um because uh it felt kind of like kind
of
quite heavy comparing to the logo um
so then i went back to the original
euclid square but
now i am making sure that
um that word um that
symbol is following um futura
uh kind of like slant or guides or
curves
and then what i'm gonna do later on is
redesign
let's rest in euclid square so that it's
built a little bit more like fedora so
that they kind of align
oh i see
things that designers do things that
drive designers crazy
it's matching letter forms and angles
right
very nice i i have a slide later on
which shows all of the
um like a progression so
hopefully you guys can tell me if it was
worth my time because that took a long
time
so this is what i'm trying to figure out
here
and let me know if you want me to rewind
any of these parts first
no so far so good so
after exploring the s and redrawing it
what are you doing now
i feel like literally for the whole
duration of this video i'm gonna be
doing that because i don't
feel uh i don't remember too well but i
feel like i haven't redrawn
as just yet okay i'll jump a bit later
on
oh yeah so okay so here you can see me
trying to fit futura
into that typeface so i can see how much
of the
weight i need to reduce
so you're literally copying and pasting
a futura s in there
yeah just to try it on for size
yeah exactly um
and then well obviously if it's always a
lot bolder than this typeface
um and so what i started doing
is matching the angles
and then
what am i doing here you're cutting off
the edges
to match the same angle and then you're
adjusting the letter form
in that open counter so that it feels
correct otherwise
it's flaring out at that angle right
yes exactly and i've already said there
that it's not working
because the whole letter felt like it's
tilting so i thought i can do like a
quick fix
to euclid's square and just make the
same
kind of like a cut in an s so that it
follows the same angle um
but it didn't work yeah
so now i'm guessing
i was just saying someone in the chat
was saying that the letter s is one of
the hardest
letters to design a vector do you guys
feel that's true it's true man
it looks like it is true there's all
kinds of weird stuff you have to take
into consideration
it's nasty to draw
so now i imported i'm gonna stop it
quickly
so what i did is that i've put futura s
into that already existing word mark
then i exported put it into my ipad
redrew it
by hand slightly so until it kind of
felt right
and now you're seeing that sketch which
i'm going to start vectorizing
so all i did is that i took kind of like
a little bit width
out of it
thanks cz design for the super chat
appreciate it
i think that's tristan right
um i'm not familiar with the name we'll
see
cz design thank you
so a lot of these decisions that you're
making lisa just kind of optical
as you're pulling in the other futuras
yeah pretty much yeah
i admire all you designers who come on
the show and try to do
design and draw a symbol they're not
very easy to do i've tried
so that's why i stick with type
i've seen you design symbols on the show
before chris
that's why i've stopped since then
they're just difficult you know to try
to capture the
essence and create something memorable
and unique
some of the ones i admire um i look at
them like oh it's perfect i just
one day one day i might get there
but not today
mark you know here i'm just creating
sorry go ahead
uh here i'm just creating a lot of uh
side by side comparisons to see what
optically feels right to me
and i'm kind of like marking them as i
go so i don't forget what changes you've
done
so mark i was thinking about something
i think you're doing this on purpose so
you wait for me to speak and then
you start talking exact same time great
reflexes okay
you go first no it's your turn
no no really i insist i don't even
remember what i was gonna say anymore
you remind me of someone that used to be
on the show with us
i would start talking and they would
just interrupt me and i would stop and
like you have something to say
and they said no i don't i don't
remember i'm like well thanks for
interrupting my flow of thinking
okay so while while you're watching you
work here i just wanted to
fill in some of the dead air which was
i've been looking around for a logo to
take on
a logo that we all could participate and
there's a lot of candidates for ugly
logos that
need some help so the first one i'm
going to throw out there to everybody
that's watching on the live stream over
500 of you
is maybe maybe the logo for under armour
needs some help
just me maybe the whole company needs
help right now but i'm just thinking
that logo
is uh but ugly but ugly do you guys feel
the same way
i feel it man unless they've changed it
it's i get it they want a
cool x letter so they do the u and the a
but they're both round and curvy and
it's just
i wouldn't want to wear that it actually
turns me off
and when your logo is that bad i won't
buy your products you know it's bad
here's another logo i i think needs some
work and this might be controversial
the ufc some some organization that i
love
and the story behind the ufc is they had
a pretty but ugly logo before
and they they had a design competition
really strange
and this is before they made it into the
big times right so that design
competition i felt compelled to like try
to enter but i was thinking
this is degrading they should just hire
a professional design firm
and do this versus having fan submitted
art
and then they have the logo that they
have today i think you need some help
the last logo i think needs a lot of
help is a company i'm hoping that will
sponsor a design competition for all of
us so that there's something in it for
you and for us
is dr squatch the soap company
they need all kinds of help they have a
good product they need all kinds of help
with packaging
website design but check this out
they're still very successful despite
not having good identity design
those are some things for you to
consider i'm gonna ask you all to think
about some logos that you
love to hate and go ahead and drop it in
the comments below
get back to you unless it is your show
what's a doctor's crush i've not heard
about dr squatch
yeah i'll share with you later yeah it's
a it's a brand of soap
for men i just google tender armor and i
really agree with you so you know what
i'm talking about now right
yeah right so i'm gonna jump ahead
because this is just me trying to work
out
optically whether that s works um
what have i done right what have i done
wrong i'm not a type designer so this
wasn't
an easy thing for me to do um
ideally you know if skillshare hired me
and i was doing this project for them i
would hire a type designer to do this
part for me
but i couldn't um
so you're still obsessing over this
letter s right now or you were
yeah my goodness how many hours of your
life
did that suck
that particular letter s
uh like maybe six but i learned a lot
doing it
okay sounds like an s load
are you rounding the corners to your
letters yes i rounded them slightly so
that
um it feels a little bit friendlier
[Music]
all these subtle little tweaks
and now i'm just seeing if this letter s
works well in combination with others
and yeah so
this is literally what i've managed to
do to it i've kind of like
redesigned um reconstructed the way that
the lesser
s is built within this typeface so that
it follows
um the same angles and curves
and here is the side by side comparison
so
here's how the on the um on the left
is how original typeface looked um
then in the middle is the modified type
like
um the tweaks that i said that i did to
it like i've
modified the width of some letters
and then on the right is how the
redesigned
version looks
yeah okay
i'm standing really hard on my screen
right now okay i see it
i see it i'm glad you're pointing it out
though
i do good
my time didn't go wasted yeah it was not
wasted i want to give a quick shout out
to nick's ui
ux thank you very much for your support
um okay so now what
i have oh my gosh you didn't even
prepare me for this you just threw it
introduce it first will you okay so this
is the final logo
yes nice right so you're using the
original
orange and turquoise
and you're also bringing back some of
that connectivity
the letter s hidden in the counter or
the duck
and ideas of uh
infinity or or a link or a chain
between teacher and student and student
becoming teacher maybe
exactly very nice very clean
yeah very clean okay so where else are
we going with this
so i started putting together some
design elements um
i felt like
wait can i have a look at my slides
really quickly oh sure
yeah so let's cut to cut to my ugly face
then
yep i'm on there yeah okay uh and back
to you now
yes yes okay what's this all about
so i started putting together some
design elements just to guide me for
their own
as um i'm going through this process and
i felt like
uh potentially some gradients like
variations of the primary color
um some gradients that are variation of
the primary color will actually help
them to
bring a little bit of youthness
and make them feel a little bit more
modern because
these two colors i think can look a
little bit heavy when they are together
so what i wanted to do is to kind of
like lighten it up a little bit
um and now i returned back to my
identity system inspiration that i had
in mind from the very beginning
uh when i was designing the logo and
actually just to say like sometimes
um i start with the system first and
design the logo
after and i really wanted to do it
i was really hoping that this is gonna
happen for this process but it didn't
make sense because already from the
beginning
i kind of knew that i want to follow i
want something that follows the shapes
of the symbol
which meant that i had to design symbol
first but sometimes
i design a whole system and then i go
back and
get the logo done um so
we're back to the inspiration and
i felt like something kind of like
intertwining shapes
um some like flowing shapes um
what could be the way to bring this to
life
and i started doing some
sketches of what i have in my mind so
that i don't spend too much time
pursuing not the correct idea
um and this is kind of like what i
started drawing so you can see those
gradient colors slightly coming in
um and what i wanna wanted to do is
like create this flow shapes that are
then
taking into you taking you into the logo
um and this is some
examples of like how it might look like
well there's some sketches of how it
would look like without
um with like still same curves but
without having the logo in there
um and then i've created a grid
that would help me construct those flow
shapes
all coming together now
[Music]
so i think i'm gonna jump somewhere so
as i've constructed those shapes i
started
seeing if i there's anything more
interesting i can do with the gradient
because when i was applying
just a normal gradient to it it looked
really flat
um and
i wanted to have kind of like this
feeling of the two colors coming and
merging together
and this is literally just me playing
around and exploring to see where it
takes me
it looks like we're getting a lot of
discussion here about gradients and
some people are saying that they're
difficult to use i know that in this
situation your research is showing that
you know you're showing that
blend together uh almost like a
metaphorical meaning
um chris so let's say you guys have any
uh
kind of pros and cons to using gradients
yes use them very carefully
because it could easily make your design
cheeseball just letting you guys know
and if you pick the right colors it can
really make it sing and be very vibrant
and pop
pick the wrong colors it's like oh
somebody just learned how to use the
gradient filter
so in this case here with the orange and
turquoise color they're complementary on
the color wheel
that means if you mix them they get
muddy and really nasty
as you can start to see here when
alyssa's painting them together you're
going to see some
really strange overlap in the colors so
i think her strategy to use a
deeper burnt umber or kind of this
reddish blood orange
to to define the orange arc is a nice
choice there i think with the turquoise
blue
you probably want to do something
similar a deeper shade of blue or maybe
a blue green
color to kind of accent that
when they overlap it gets it gets a
little crazy
right yeah absolutely and
as i was going i was using a lot of
references because it was really
difficult to get
a uh balance right especially
like for that reason as you very well
describe chris
um and also on the use of gradient i
definitely i think it should be a
careful use because
what i feel like sometimes happens is
that it's kind of like
get out of jail free card for a lot of
designers like oh i
haven't designed something really well
so i'm gonna apply a gradient to it and
make it
pop or like look nicer um
it's like you have to have good bones in
your design
otherwise you're throwing an ugly or a
dress on top and the bones aren't there
it's it doesn't look right
are there any cases where you shouldn't
use a gradient at all
yeah when you have a low budget for
printing
and you you or perhaps when you have to
deal with something that
has to be very very legible then it's
just probably better to use solid colors
or especially if like people are
colorblind in those applications
i like imagine a stop sign having
gradient red orange and yellow and you
see it you're like well sometimes i see
stop and sometimes i just see sto
right that's why you need just contrast
contrast
is king indesign
it seems like you're just exploring here
right it's like
yes i had absolutely no idea what i was
doing
i'll try this no that didn't work i'll
try that okay
i'll try this transfer mode
it's all part of the sometimes
sometimes when you play with them
actually some really interesting things
that you wouldn't expect come out so
photoshop i think is definitely my
favorite
program to design and mindlessly like if
you have to be a bit more intentional if
you're doing something in indesign well
indesign is layout so obviously you have
to be but like
um illustrator for example like i would
not be able to design anything there
with just
playing around like i feel i need to be
quite intentional with what i'm doing
but photoshop especially if you're
working with
color is a really nice kind of like
playground
place at least for me now there's a lot
of questions in the chat about why these
colors
are not feeling it but what you don't
understand if you go back to the
beginning
at this time timeline or the video
you'll notice that the original colors
for skillshare are
the same or similar turquoise and orange
right
yes that's that's so she's trying to go
back into the history
and oftentimes as designers we feel
compelled to just throw away everything
that's come before because we want to
put our own stamp on it and that's not
always appropriate
so i like that list is kind of staying
in in the pocket if you will
of speaking to the past while pointing
to the future
and that's where the blue and orange or
the turquoise and orange come come from
yeah they are not very easy colors to
make work together though
let me rephrase in case somebody pulls a
sound bite from this video
let me rephrase concept is king
contrast is queen
okay i'll just leave the mic here
[Laughter]
this is why it's so hard to do these
live streams without a live audience
you know what i mean i got no love from
jonah or mark yikes
i got nothing from you guys no i'm
leaving the sound bites for the edit
later
[Laughter]
yeah thanks jonah thanks it's like a
sprint commercial you can hear the pin
drop
it's tough this crowd is very tough you
guys you think this job is easy
this job's not easy at all
what's going on imagine
don't know what the sound effects
yes how many live streams do you do a
day usually chris
four i'm just kidding
i i do one if if possible in the maximum
but
sometimes i do podcasts i do coaching
calls and then i do a live stream
last week was particularly brutal on me
and the the team wanted to see how much
punishment i could take and so
i had multiple podcasts in a day as well
as multiple live streams in a day
so that one was rough this the whole
weekend i spent like
just on my back like oh i can't even
open my eyes right now
just trying to keep you on your feet
yeah but you knocked me on my back
so listen what's going on here you're
introducing different colors and then
masking to see if they all kind of blend
together
yeah so it's all a combination of a lot
of masking a lot of different blend
modes
um mostly pin light blend mode because
it kind of like pushes color around
nicely and
i'm kind of still staying with the same
um
[Music]
initial idea of adding
additional color like addition
additional colors into
the teal and orange
but sort of seeing if i can make all of
them work at the same time
i love color yes you do it's
it's pretty wild i have to admit right
now it's pretty wild
yes how do you know you're going to be
done i mean it's just like you're just
painting away
at some point i feel like i just know
okay it's not a helpful answer i'm sorry
it's like i i i know it when i see it
that's the answer you're giving us right
now
uh okay so for for the sake of everybody
here we probably need to like jump
forward to like when this starts to come
together maybe at a
greater milestone okay so this is the
final thing here yes okay cool let's see
that so
so i've stopped at this gradient um but
i think something exciting can start
happening if you sort of
vary it a little interesting mm-hmm
and oh and context here looks
yeah so
i've also added a bit of copy in there
to go back into the idea of um
a place where inspiration finds you so
when we show up inspiration
follows which i think is a really nice
positive message for a learning platform
to
send because learning can be really
painful sometimes
and it's nice to have a bit of
encouragement
actually i think learning is it's pretty
painless it's the doing part that's
painful right
we can sit here and listen when you put
into action it can
actually be very painful especially when
you're learning something new
i love seeing it in context like on a
scale like this on a big screen where
i could see the keynote being delivered
and somebody's standing there and that's
their slide
right i think that's really cool as as a
standalone piece of art
it needs some type to ground it and
adding the logo underneath and this copy
and the people it really starts to come
to life nicely done i can see this
animated too
yeah absolutely okay
uh i think those shapes could be quite
interesting if you start
um because what they do is that they
receive a lot of content
from their creators and having
some sort of system or a shape that
helps them to generate those graphics
can be really helpful
and what if they've released a billboard
or some sort of advertising
you could start i'm sure
um if they were actually commissioning
an ad campaign
it would look different but it would it
is
there is something interesting in using
the shapes of the logo and just
you know driving a bit more brand
recognition for that
i like this crop in particular i think
seeing the
shapes not fully formed like a hint of
the shape as the
left bottom edge there i think something
like that is really
cool for my own taste i think it would
be much more successful if you use a
little less color and
and just hinted at the shapes joan is
that you
not me you calling somebody
okay that's me yeah so i i think
just like if i if we were in in in
design
workshop together i would say yeah i
think you're on to something i just
would pull back some of the colors and
use a little bit more restraint
and i think you're on to something
really nice i love the crops i love
seeing it in different proportions where
it's squarish and then it's very
really horizontal and it's starting to
show like oh there's a lot of places you
can take this
and there's a dimensionality to it
that's coming through here where it
feels like things are
undulating and coming forward in space
and things are folding back even though
it's just
strictly two-dimensional
okay okay well i can imagine a lot of
places where this could go unfortunately
i stopped there
okay that's fair that's a lot of places
you already imagined for us
but i will be i will keep expanding this
project so
i'll be dropping some stuff as i make it
okay so let's keep this up on screen
skillshare about a year ago went
underwent a rebrand and
the logo on the left the black and green
one the lime green
is what they netted out at and alyssa
felt like oh
and she's she's a fan and she felt a
little disappointed because it felt
typical or
just in keeping with what everybody else
is doing and it lost a lot of its
history and roots
and so she wanted to bring that back the
interlocking hands the
the infinity symbol i say that with a
little smile and the
turquoise and orange color palette the
mix and match thank you very much
the mix and match of those two coming
together right
so if you look at the colored version of
the skillshare logo you'll see that they
split the letter forms into blue and
orange
or turquoise and orange and that's where
that comes from okay let's go back to
the previous
slide and i'm gonna ask everybody do you
prefer the original
type in one in the comments or do you
like
where else is taking it with the rebrand
refresh but going back to the history
put number two in the comments and we'll
see where we net out
i know that's going to take a little
time for us to tally the results and for
you to actually hear this
because of the audio delay or the live
stream delay
let's see what they say one original
two new already getting some results in
here
because we saw the original slide but
yes lots of people
like the revised the after number two
nice with a few yeah there's some ones
mixed in but the majority is
the majority yeah vast majority and
somebody gave you a dab
emoji icon so
one more time what's that one more time
no no it's too late i gave it to you oh
you guys are slow on the trigger
if you're slowing the trigger general
what can i say okay
yeah i would like to i would like to
give you some of my critique and
observations here i think you did a
wonderful job i loved how you
deconstructed the logo
and like i said it's a big challenge to
try and come up with a symbol that is
pleasing that
has some meaning but not so strong that
it becomes only
one thing that's critical when you're
designing
an icon for a company that is still
growing and changing
some of the observations here i noticed
the the macaroni shapes that you did the
the lower
part of the s there seems to be a little
swelling in the the bowl of the s and it
seems a little thicker there for some
reason it could just be because of the
way i'm looking at my screen
and the top of the s the the orange
macaroni
it looks a little heavy on the top side
so there's some
some things that are just throwing me
off ever so slightly listen
i need to go and look at your vector
file to be sure but
it's just optical it looks like it's
slightly crescent and i'm not quite sure
why and then it seems to swell
at the bottom of the as the bowl okay
uh i would like to see a little bit more
refinement there
i really like the extent in which you
went in and started to
modify the letter form so that there's
some continuity some
some visual compatibility or
complementary
lines and angles so that they they seem
to fit together
most of the other letter forms are
pretty generic so that i i think was
wise to focus on the s and
tie those two together and i also like
that you
you brought the colors back
that's it okay even after you said that
you like the green color
no i say i i like that you brought the
colors back the the the turquoise and
orange
just pulling from history oh um
did i manage to change your mind
[Laughter]
are you trying to put me on the spot a
little bit
i let me let me let me say it this way i
i think there are
two very handsome options here and i i
think if i were skillshare i'd be very
happy to choose either
oh that's a good answer
okay very good so i guess i think that's
it for us right mark do we have any
other questions or comments that we need
to read from the chats
um there was one question so i know you
mentioned some of those um
designers in the beginning the ones that
created those prints um
who are they again uh one was carol
martens
carol martens carol martins
yeah what else who else i think that's
the only one
that's the only one okay yeah okay i
have a question for you though in
regards to the font
that you use i i'm always on the search
for like interesting fonts and like why
people use them
and most often times it's they're
terrible fonts and they're not really
well drawn
but i like this one euclid square so i
looked it up on their site and it's
i'm trying to i'm trying to buy it but
there's a couple of steps i have to
figure out
because it won't show me the price how
much did that font cost you
uh it is quite an expensive font i used
it for a client project
um which they
have bought for their company and now
unless i use it for a commercial project
right sometimes i just use it for
personal needs
i got it i got what you're saying i'm
just curious like do you remember how
much the
complete set the different weights cost
i only have three weights of it and
i think it was about 800 pounds or more
800 pounds wow holy smoker rooney's
all right okay everybody just like
emptied their
shopping cart right now wow
okay usually small type boundaries that
are really good at crafting typefaces
their typefaces cost more because they
just don't sell a whole lot
right so just let you guys know anyways
um i
i just want to thank you for for doing
uh logotherapy logo redo with us as
one of our newest additions to the
therapist if you will i appreciated your
your work your efforts and your energy
and putting this together
very nice presentation and i think you
ended up with a very solid solution
so if you guys are curious if you're
curious you can find out more about
alyssa
she's alyssa metznick and it's at
alyssa.works
and she's residing in ireland but she's
originally from estonia
and you can check out her website you're
in london
yes not in ireland no okay i don't i
wish i was an island it's very beautiful
i thought that came in you're with your
bio okay whatever she's in london she's
in london guys
so it's a list or you go to her website
alyssa.works
and if you're a a client and you have
needs of a skilled designer i would
highly encourage you to go check her out
and to hire the people who do this work
for us that we can enjoy and learn from
and that's it for me on on behalf of the
rest of the team jonah and mark alyssa
thank you very much
i want to wish you guys have a great
weekend and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and hit the bell
for notifications
that's it for us guys i will see you
next time where you may see me dabbing
or not who knows
dad and chris thank you so much thank
you all right
out of here bye guys